I don't think we're gonna be like a fun
time my new friends in Japan huh
oh my god welcome to Kagurazaka huntin
in Tokyo Japan where we are about to do
I can't believe I'm gonna say this the
giant gyoza challenge here the rules I
get one hour to eat one giant gyoza oh
oh Sh which weighs 5 pounds this weighs
like the size of a large bag of potato I
don't know I had no come to what this is
it cost me ninety six hundred yen and if
you finish it you don't have to pay I've
got a few friends here some ladies from
the BuzzFeed Japan office let's get the
skills of going let's get this girl's it
going how hungry are you I'm pretty
hungry
I had ramen for breakfast which me in
hindsight probably was a bad idea
t-minus four hours until we got to eat
the dumpling was this a good decision
no so you have the timer you have 60
minutes I've got warm water because I
hear that if you drink cold water it
makes all the dough coagulate in your
intestines faster which we don't want
we've got salt chili oil vinegar and soy
sauce and on the inside I believe it is
some pork scallion garlic you know your
your typical gay of the filling
we've officially begun the challenge oh
wow look at that oh you know if they
always say first cut is the deepest
[Music]
how's that taste
oh it's really good feeling I feel like
I'm carving the next Michelangelo except
to see gyoza and I'm eating it Bo the
back
gyoza has a signature dumpling of Japan
no I think I think I'm crossing it so
far right now it's like no matter how
much I eat it doesn't get any smaller
I'm fun this is fun time I chose this on
my own
listen and will oh there's a city that I
don't know how to pronounce called you
soon Oh Maya thank you that actually has
the highest capita for a consumption of
gears in Japan Wow my new friends in
Japan hurt oh my god that was close
I'm gonna take my first sip of water
mind over matter time feels infinite and
so quickly at the same time I don't know
I think I have sodium poisoning how much
would you say I did I think you've
gotten about like a 20th ah okay you're
fine
so basically I've decided since I've
only you know about 1/6 of this and I
feel like I'm going to die
this video has changed from can I eat
Aghios a giant gyoza in an hour - how
many people does it take to eat a giant
gyoza in one hour we've got 44 minutes
left so hurt it's so bad so did you eat
today already I had fried chicken for
breakfast had a girl that a girl sorry
do you think we should bring another
person in don't you stop either you're
not sorry
no you love gyoza the level of love I
have for use' is very close to be metal
if I have what a great answer your
cheese ball well we only have 34 minutes
left so you better eat bastard how you
doing over here you're just kind of
you're just pushing food around the
plate now now remember when I first sat
down I said it didn't look that big but
the official count up to four people do
you like yoga I love you listen have you
ever seen one this big what do you think
it's really good I'm gonna start like
kind of making this a pile of things
that we're leaving behind we don't want
any left behind what do you think
[Music]
strong reaction from our girl lemme over
there okay well we've got 24 minutes
left this is my mom everybody go good
do you like use it I love meatloaf
that's not what they do
let's see what's the first bite mmm I
see one empty plate two empty place few
people
[Music]
[Music]
you know what we were here for you but
you probably should do this on your own
yeah yeah you can do it I couldn't have
done it without you as we come to the
last bite do I feel good no do I like
myself though don't know but did I have
fun absolutely not
but if you think you can tackle the
dying deals or challenge the my hats are
literally off you serious farther than
you've been some by
[Music]
just to conclude it's a seven people
fifty minutes to finish
five pounds of gyoza if you can do it on
your own you are a superhero how do you
say that in Japanese big thank you to
the restaurant and the chef thank you so
very much for cooking this rice thrown
in the towel thrown in the gyoza
eight minutes to spare
[Music]
you